ae
esse é o culpado
vocês conhecem na e atinge até 115
quilômetros por hora mas já que o meu
carro porque eu tô falando disso
só para lembrar que nós não somos
mamíferos mais rápidos que existem
também não é novidade nenhuma dizer que
não somos os mais fortes caraíba foto
levantar até 10 vezes o próprio peso
eu não consigo levantar o meu acerto
acerto não só dos humanos mais fortes
que existem mas acho que nem o mais
brutal montes da nossa espécie é páreo
para o burlão africano
então assim não somos os mais rápidos
não somos os mais fortes
não chegamos nem perto de sermos os
maiores baleias um mede 30 metros era 17
vezes maior do que a gente é assim
talvez sejamos os mais inteligentes
eu tenho minhas dúvidas o fato é que
seja lá como a gente vai parar neste
planeta
a gente veio com uma missão bem
complicada sobreviver no meio das feras
no meio das chuvas o calor escaldante ao
frio congelante
há uma abundância tímida uma escassez
descarada
no começo da nossa caminhada aqui nesse
planeta depende totalmente do acaso na
nossa estância da nossa perspicácia né
a gente estava suscetível aos rompantes
da natureza ao ataque de predadores ou
de outro de nossa própria espécie né
era bem se por si e deus contra todos
como dizia meu irmão mas aí um belo dia
a gente começou a pegar o ritmo da terra
a gente aprendeu a plantar a gente foi
abandonando o nomadismo gente encontrou
um cantinho pra ficar
foi nesse dia que um dos nossos
antepassados sacou tudo quanto mais nós
fizermos as coisas juntos mais chances a
gente tem de sobreviver
e foi essa parada e de juntos somos mais
fortes que surgiu a idéia de contrato
social esse contato social dizia aqui
vamos passar pela
juntos lado a lado com a sociedade ei
contrato social assinado debaixo do
braço lá fomos nós sobreviver né
então foi um tal de casar filhos com a
filha do vizinho de expandir as terras
de expandir as posses de expandir os
poderes
esse pessoal e real benefício nessa
coisa de embora lá junto todo mundo
fazer isso de parte geral contribuir com
que a gente sabe o que a gente pode
o tempo foi passando e de famílias a
gente pulou para tribo de trigo a gente
construiu vilas de vidas de partir para
as cidades e das cidades metrópoles e aí
sobreviver já não era mais o suficiente
bom agora viver viver com conforto ver
com luxo e aí a gente saiu das cavernas
nas ocas nas tendas nas cabanas nas
casas e nos palácios a gente chegou nas
coberturas do leblon
sei lá se isso eu vou eu acho que talvez
não seja evolução fato é que a gente
ficou mesmo muito bom nessa coisa de
sobreviver de colaborar e aí tem até uma
história pra contar pra vocês sobre isso
em 1755 40 entre 40 e 50 mil pessoas
morreram no terremoto em lisboa foi
seguido de incêndio e de tsunami tudo ao
mesmo tempo agora
um dos sobreviventes dessa mega
catástrofe foi marquês de pombal
marquês de pombal bradou lá do alto dos
escombros enterremos os mortos
queremos os livros não foram os
indivíduos empoderadas pelo sentimento
de pertença que reconstruíram lisboa das
cinzas é o segredo né verdade é
irrefutável e toda a nossa trajetória
aqui nesse planeta
as nossas maiores vitórias passaram pelo
fato de termos desapegado do ego
e juntos temos partidos partido para a
reconstrução ou para a construção de
algo muito maior
isso é o que a gente convencionou chamar
de sinergia
então quando o bicho pega pega pra geral
pega pra rico era pobre
enio pega pra medíocre eventos de vida
ou morte não existe seleção por um time
de futebol favorito por cor de pele
estilo de cabelo e para sobreviver a
esses eventos de vida ou morte
não tinha essa de eu aqui e você lá
vamos nós nós é nós bonito isso né
bonita essa coisa de é o nome bonito mas
para cada uma das nossas vitórias
coletivas sempre surge uma linda lenda
de um herói
salvador é em lisboa existe uma enorme
estátua para a marquês de pombal mas não
existe para os tantos que enterraram os
mortos procuraram os vivos gente
alimenta desde sempre
esse mito do cara que vem e sozinho
coloca as coisas no lugar
então não é por acaso que a descrição de
self made man no fred douglas 1895 onde
benjamin franklin que é um pouquinho
anterior e cachê tão bem essa idéia de
herói e também não é por acaso que eles
descreveram isso num momento de quebra
total de paradigmas revolução industrial
e é na revolução industrial que nasceu
sistema que a gente conhece tão bem
sistema educacional no sistema
educacional esse ideal de self made man
encontrou uma morada super confortável
na forma da valorização da performance
individual exercício prova comportamento
é um sistema educacional ele foi capaz
de criar uma bonificação por bom
comportamento premiação para os alunos
com melhor nota
a pontuação extra para exercícios feitos
em sala de aula ou fora da sala de aula
sistema educacional foi capaz de dividir
turmas por desempenho individual
não houve e há desde sempre um reforço
da cultura do vale ma e faça sozinho
desde sempre a gente é instigado
motivado a não olhar para o lado a não
copiar a privilegiar o eu antes de nós
isso é muito importante isso é muito
importante mas talvez já não seja mais o
suficiente porque a galera já está
passando por um pouco he de crise é
crise climática hídrica política de
crédito de confiança tem tudo para tudo
e essas crises elas são o somatório das
nossas decisões civilizatórias dos
estilos de vida que adotamos os modelos
econômicos que nós escolhemos do sistema
educacional que nós honramos e aí a
fatura a conta chegou só decidiu abrir
essa fatura agora vos fala que ela foi
paga com crédito lá atrás
alguém vai ter que pagar essa conta
parece que somos nós e sá e aí pra pagar
essa conta eu acredito que a gente
precisa de mais nós e de - eu e como a
gente vai fazer isso eu sugiro que seja
pelas escolas
começamos nas escolas que lugar melhor
do que a escola para que a gente promova
cidadãos que sejam mais ativos mais
envolvidos com apólices cidadãos que
estejam mais aptos a acolher os espaços
físicos da cidade assume com a
responsabilidade de vencer é isso
moleza beleza como é que faz faz
eu fiquei me perguntando como eu faço
para jogar sinergy catarse pra dentro da
educação
e aí a minha resposta passa por um
método quatro atitudes poderosas e cinco
ferramentas que sejam apropriadas para
esse momento 145 esquema tático do
futebol mesmo esquema ousado é tipo
assim vamos ganhar isso é tipo seleção
brasileira de 70 outros tempos de março
o meu de março começa com a defesa da
aprendizagem por projetos porque ela que
gera autonomia ela que acolhe olhar
genuíno olhar curioso ela quem instiga o
análise crítica ela que promove
uma co criação não aprendizagem projetos
quatro atitudes poderosas na meiuca como
a gente diz lá no rio
a primeira delas acolher é preciso
acolher a empatia como um meio para
gerar como conhecimento não como fim é
mais interessante usar empatia como
conexão para o conhecimento do que usar
o conhecimento como conexão para empatia
eu quero dizer com isso ao invés de
criarmos uma linda sobre mobilidade
urbana para gerar empatia nos nossos
alunos que tal partimos da empatia dos
nossos alunos pelo trânsito na cidade
daí gerarmos conhecimento a gente quer
sinergia e catarse na educação é preciso
que a gente esteja pronto para acolher a
empatia genuína dos aprendizes dos pais
e dos educadores segunda atitude
poderosa e experimentar
é preciso que a gente tome a educação
como um espaço mais autónomo é preciso
que as escolas tenham espaços mais
livres de experimentação é preciso que a
gente aceite que no fundo no fundo tudo
tudo que a gente faz é beta experimento
temporário eo quanto antes a gente
aceitar isso
mais perto a gente vai estar de inovar a
educação transversalizar porque acredito
que existe um outro lugar para o
educador na relação de
ensino-aprendizagem esse outro lugar e
fora do palco é transversal é um lugar
de sensibilidade ao lugar de proximidade
é um lugar de afeto
a gente precisa de mais mentores
a gente precisa de mais tutores a gente
precisa de mais guias
a gente precisa de menos professores que
professam que ditam quem põe e vivenciar
porque acredito que a gente pode ver se
a educação em qualquer lugar e qualquer
lugar é um espaço educacional
a gente quer reviver esse sentimento de
pertença então é preciso que as crianças
caminham pelas ruas
é preciso que elas conheçam os becos das
farmácias é preciso que elas conheçam as
praças
é preciso que elas conheçam as padarias
por que não uma aula sobre maria
antonieta
a revolução francesa os brioches uma
padaria e no meu ataque só tem fera
são cinco ferramentas por uma educação
que seja mais viva afetiva e livre
primeira delas é o diálogo tônico
eu não sei se vocês sabem vocês devem
saber sou eu que a gente fala muito mais
com os nossos gestos e com o nosso olhar
o nosso jeito porque com as nossas
palavras e é preciso que a gente esteja
pronto para expressar e receber de aula
o tônico diálogo em infravermelho
como é que faz isso exercício de
psicomotricidade por exemplo escuta
afetiva porque um dos meus ted talks
favoritos é o do júlio andré gewehr
não sei se vocês já ouviram falar nele
ele disse que nós estamos perdendo a
nossa capacidade de ouvir
nós estamos perdendo nossa capacidade de
distinguir os sons e fiquei preocupado
com isso e eu comecei a praticar um
exercício que eu chamo de lasanha
eletrônica eletrônica é assim que eu
quero uma folha de papel
o traço e chukchis o eixo y x é a
duração da música y é o número de
batidas que eu consigo identificar uma
música eo bota uma música eletrônica
para tocar eu desenho gráfico é um
exercício que o trabalho a minha
concentração especialmente à minha saúde
auditiva
recomendo muito visão sistêmica porque
quantas vezes a gente já não transportou
nossa vida pessoal os nossos problemas
familiares para dentro de uma relação
que trabalho
quantas vezes a gente já não projetou
uma frustração um problema um incômodo
na nossa relação com os aprendizes com
os colegas de trabalho mas é um sistema
que ela tem uma técnica chamada posição
perceptual em que a gente se convida a
entrar no campo de uma outra pessoa
entrar no mapa do mundo de uma outra
pessoa e promover o entendimento empatia
e respeito ferramenta linda design
thinking porque é uma ferramenta que
produz cocriação inteligência coletiva é
uma ferramenta de resolução de problemas
ela também uma ferramenta que
ajuda manifestar ideias que promove o
aprendizado pelo processo entrega é
menos importante que o processo e por
fim um forte fator landim e porque
acredito que essa ferramenta de
etnografia de pesquisa etnográfica ela é
essencial pra gente produzir cidadania
ativa a gente produzir intervenção
urbana impacto social como é que faz
isso onde pode seguir um roteiro de
ferramentas tenha árvore problema por
exemplo é uma técnica de identificação
de oportunidades ou corte transversal
pra gente saber que camada da sociedade
esse problema se manifesta essa
oportunidade é problema oportunidade
onde se manifesta ou as técnicas de
ranking para que a gente tenha uma
tomada de decisão que seja mais genuína
mas legítima mas coletiva
a galera na boa
tudo isso que estou falando para vocês
aqui reflete o meu mapa do mundo a minha
leitura de cenário reflete a leitura do
cenário da minha a minha escola de
projetos o extra muros no rio é muito
influenciado também pela inspiração do
meu avô
o cara de 97 anos que saiu do sertão da
bahia virou diretor de contabilidade de
uma grande empresa sem nunca ter pisado
numa escola
ele é a escola e vocês também são então
fique à vontade para discordar
eu acredito muito na colisão a coesão de
idéias é fundamental para a inovação sem
coalizão de 10 não há inovação 145 esse
esquema tático que eu adotei como
educador workshops nos cursos nas
melhorias com crianças com adolescentes
com adultos e até idosos
isso tem trazido muita expansão de
consciência muita autonomia muita
cidadania ativa especialmente muito bem
está bem está para baa1 mãe também está
o fim do último da educação
se a gente acredita mesmo que o bem
estar é o fim último da educação é
preciso que a gente recupere para já o
nosso espírito de comunidade
a nossa capacidade de sentir pertença
preciso que a gente acolher melhor os
espaços públicos é preciso fazer mais
política com menos político sentimento
de pertença uma coisa muito séria gente
à minha cidade niterói
eu acho que ela dormiu em uma cidade
dormitório é porque a gente a maioria
das pessoas trabalha no rio niterói só
para dormir e isso adormeceu a nossa
capacidade de sentir pertença e só do
mês eu o espírito de comunidade da minha
cidade mas acho que não foi só ele terá
que dormir ou não eu acho que tem um
monte de cidade por aí domingo esperando
sei lá uma solução divina
a gente não quer mais
o despertador já tocou há muito tempo
não dá pra apertar soneca
não dá pra pedir nós somos cinco
minutinhos não dá não dá mais é hora de
acordar é hora de acolher os espaços
é hora de acolher empatia gerar e
acolher empatia é hora de uma educação
que seja mais transformadora é hora de
uma educação que desperta uma educação
para que as cidades vivam obrigado